as a scientist working on Alzheimer's
disease for many years it's fantastic
that our years of fundamental
Neuroscience research have finally
resulted in a treatment that can affect
the disease process so this drug which I
was not involved in can slow the
progression of Alzheimer's disease like
you mentioned by about 27 percent and it
can reverse some of the pathological
changes in the brain that sticky amyloid
is being cleared from the brain well yes
and explain to us in basic terms what
Alzheimer's does to the brain and how
does this drug combat that
so Alzheimer's disease is the most
common cause of dementia dementia is the
symptoms that your viewers are probably
all very well aware of this devastating
loss of mental function and Alzheimer's
disease is caused by a very slow buildup
of two sticky proteins in the brain one
is amyloid that builds up for decades
before you even have symptoms and the
other is Tau that clumps up inside your
brain cells and spreads through the
brain as your symptoms progress and this
drug targets the amyloid which is a very
early part of the disease process and
that's why the trial was run and people
in the early stages of disease what the
drug is is an antibody that's infused in
your bloodstream every two weeks and it
binds up that sticky amyloid peptide and
brings it out of the brain and that
allows some some recovery of of brain
function or at least slowing of the
progression of cognitive decline well
yes and so as you were implying there
the drugs have to be given early in the
uh early on since diagnosis of
Alzheimer's so does that present
challenges in making sure that people
are diagnosed early how difficult is
that
yes because you have brain changes for
many years before you have any symptoms
it's very difficult to know exactly
who's in the early stages of disease but
we're getting better and better at
understanding who these people are by
tests like brain scans and uh cerebral
spinal fluids so spinal fluid markers
and even there are promising blood tests
but it's a little bit tricky because
this amyloid builds up not only in
people in the early stages of
Alzheimer's disease but in some of us
who are healthy and undergoing normal
aging but not on the way to Alzheimer's
disease so this trial picked people who
were in the early stages had symptoms
and had this amyloid in their brains so
clearly a great progress is being made
but what hope is there that this could
lead us on to to diagnosing and treating
later stages of Alzheimer's and perhaps
slowing it down even faster than this
drug is doing so far
well exactly I'm very optimistic we have
a lot of hope so this particular drug
hasn't been tested yet and people in
later stages of the disease and it will
be tested so people will will know
whether it's going to work at later
stages but what else this does is it
opens the door for more funding
historically Alzheimer's disease and
dementia research has received much less
funding than things like cancer research
but now that we have this proof of
principle that there can be a drug that
gets into the brain and slows disease
progression what the hope is is that
will bring more investment so that
people like us in the lab can keep doing
our work in the brain and there are
targets coming through in clinical
trials that are very exciting so not
just targeting this early amyloid but
targeting that later Tau protein there
are drugs that are being tested for that
now there are drugs that are being
tested to look at how we could affect
the brain's immune system to stop its
negative effects and the early effects
on Alzheimer's disease so it is very
very hopeful that this is just the
beginning of the end as I've heard
people call it today so lots is very
positive how soon might this drug get
rolled out
that's hard to know so I'm not on the
Committees that decide these sort of
things I'm not a medical doctor I'm a
fundamental Scientist by understanding
is this could be approved for use in the
United States fairly quickly I think it
will take longer if it is approved in
the UK because it does have side effects
so something that the authors were very
clear about in the paper about the trial
is that compared to the placebo there
were more side effects than people
taking the drug so people who have to
make the decisions about whether this
will be available on the NHS will have
to balance that risk versus benefit type
profile okay it'll be fascinating to see
how that that pans out but Professor
Tara aspires at Jones really lovely to
talk to you about such a a positive
positive development thanks very much
indeed
thank you